depuis décembre 2019 la station
d'épuration carré de réunions à
installer sa nouvelle unité de
biométhanisation capable de produire de
l'énergie
l'objectif des injections de biométhane
dans le réseau de gaz grdf et de
produire des énergies renouvelables
locales
il s'agit de d'utiliser l'énergie
produite par la station pour faire en
sorte que plutôt que de brûler
cette énergie avec une torchère
transformer le biométhane l'injecter
dans le réseau de gaz là j'étais dans le
réseau de gaz pourquoi pour alimenter
soit des bus c'est pour ça que vous avez
des bus au gaz ici soit du chauffage
urbain
et puis c'est aussi pour faire baisser
la facture pour 2020 hydrolyse se
concentre sur de nouveaux projets
notamment sur la trajectoire des eaux
usées et des eaux pluviales entre la
station d'épuration et saint quentin en
yvelines
on souhaite aussi travailler sur la
liaison qu'on appelle liaison saint
quentin en yvelines qui permet en fait
de ramener des effluents au plus près de
la station la plus proche de ses
effluents là à traiter
donc ça représente à peu près 4000 4
millions de mètres cubes qui vont être
qui peuvent potentiellement à traiter
dans la station d'épuration la
réhabilitation des collecteurs en
assainissement et la mise aux normes de
la station d'épuration de villepreux
seront également des projets abordés
durant l'année